good morning John I've been keeping a
secret from everyone and I'm going to
tell you about it today so going through
chemotherapy unsurprisingly worst thing
that's ever happened to my body I don't
really know how to talk about
chemotherapy except that it sucks like
immediately and then like gets a little
better but then always gets a little bit
worse with like moments of it getting
it's like the Star Wars prequels like
you think maybe it's starting to make a
little bit of sense and then it'll be
like I don't like
sand it's coarse and rough and
irritating I'm sorry if you like the
prequels I'm an old guy one of the
things that chemo does to you is it
makes it very hard to think because your
body's all messed up I don't know why
but it's not like you can't think you
just have to think in very specific ways
like I couldn't watch a movie but I
could watch Seinfeld I couldn't write
fiction at all but I could write
non-fiction I think everybody who does
chemo gets extremely good at at least
one mobile game like I was infinite on
Marvel snap which you don't know what
that means or maybe you do in which case
I that I did that this isn't a cancer
thing but I feel generally much better
if I feel like I can create things and
it was very hard to make stuff while
doing cancer treatment because your body
feels bad your brain feels bad they're
not working together very well but I
discovered something that I could do I
could design socks there was something
about it that was just like the right
kind of task for me it was just like one
step at a time one shape at a time one
line at a time you can step away from it
and come back you can do it over a long
period of time you can fall asleep while
you're doing it wake back up up start
doing it again and as I was doing it
with my brain locked in this particular
situation I got really obsessed with
three different things first I wanted
more socks that were just patterns weird
patterns fun patterns interesting
patterns but just patterns second I
wanted every pair of socks to use the
exact same color palette so that if they
ever became real I could mix and match
if I couldn't find a pair in that moment
I could just pair up two unmatching
socks but they would still match and
maybe I have a little fun with that and
three I was very taken with the idea
that these docks could help other people
feel as bad as I was feeling in that
moment right then which is a weird way
of saying uh while I was going through
cancer treatment I was pretty obsessed
with the reality that I was extremely
lucky like I was lucky to live at a time
and in a place where the treatment for
my disease was available and I was
probably going to be okay hodkin
lymphoma is a curable cancer if you get
it and get treatment you have almost a
90% chance of dying of some other thing
when you're old and these treatments are
old and they're not that expensive but
they are hard to get to different places
John a couple of weeks ago you made a
video about a kid in Sierra Leon who
spent years waiting to be diagnosed with
Hodgkins and then more years before he
was able to get the good chemo at a
hospital in Rwanda a journey of over
4,000 miles it just shouldn't be that
way and there are people who are working
really hard to have it not be that way
and so 100% of the profit from these
socks is going to go towards making
cancer treatment more available to more
people in this world part of the money
will be going to the very Hospital in
Rwanda that Monday was treated at and
now I would like to show them to you my
cancer socks come in two flavors there's
morning and evening and can I tell you
exactly why I feel like one of them has
the vibe of the morning and one the vibe
of the evening not really but these ones
that you've seen so far are morning and
these ones that you're looking at now
these are the evening socks they come in
three different sizes that's more than
the awesome socks sizes so if you have
like little feet that will be more
satisfied I'm sorry to all the people
who haven't been awesome sock
subscribers cuz your feet are too little
at the product page you can click on the
style that you want morning evening or
all eight and you can click on the size
they're comfy and they're cozy they're
stylish I hid a pelican on every one of
them they're all designed by Hank Green
and I don't want to brag but this is an
excellent gift for anyone for any reason
cool socks designed by a weird guy on
the internet who is going through cancer
treatment and all the money goes to make
cancer treatment more equitable what
else could you ask for they're available
at good do store or there's a link in
the description or you can just Google
Hanks cancer socks John I'll see you on
Tuesday and John yes the rumors are true
if you order early there is a chance
that I will put one of my prize
collection of antique Garfield in your
cancer socks box there's even a very
small chance that you will get an OD